[Musique]
bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
pour un nouveau numéro du 7 8 sociétés
elles les déchets véritable marée qui
nous envahit le temps de dégradation
d'une brique de lait et de cinq mois
trois mois pour un mouchoir en papier et
sans à milan pour une bouteille en
plastique
leur recyclage nous coûte 10 milliards
d'euros chaque année
comment réduire nos déchets et minimiser
l'impact sur l'environnement c'est le
sujet du jour avec nous en plateau ce
soir pour en parler
martha dos idrac sénatrice et les
républicains des yvelines
bonjour bonsoir à côté monsieur jean
michel chevalier vice président à la
collecte valorisation des déchets de
saint quentin en yvelines conseiller
communautaire délégué mais pas de souci
bonsoir bonsoir en face monsieur tony
landes ali vous êtes engagés dans la
réduction des déchets de façon
écologique dans votre résidence à
montigny le bretonneux
on y reviendra tout à l'heure sur votre
gauche sacha bourguet vous avez lancé
l'antenne de youth for climate à saint
quentin en yvelines et enfin monsieur
syrie klein membre du collectif very
green de la verrière soit merci à tous
d'avoir accepté notre invitation
elle les déchets composés principalement
des emballages plastiques deux cartons
sont présents dans notre quotidien et
notre environnement dans les yvelines
nous avons plusieurs exemples comme la
décharge sauvage de carrières sous
poissy une loi gaspillage et économie
circulaire présenté le 27 septembre a
été adopté à l'unanimité moins une voix
c'est rare malgré un embouteillage
législatif le texte est est est
actuellement examiné à l'assemblée
nationale martin décidera que vous êtes
la rapporteur de cette loi et sénatrice
des yvelines
quelles sont elles les grandes lignes de
cette loi alors cette loi a pour
vocation effectivement de s'atteler à ce
que l'on appelle l'économie circulaire
et le gaspillage le gaspillage de
consommation générale nous avons
introduit au sénat d'ailleurs un volet
sur l'aspect alimentaire également du
gaspillage mais en 2000 c'était un texte
dans le projet de loi initial qui était
structurée sur quatre grands titres
un volet 1
mation de consommateurs un volet pour
lentilles gaspillage enfin la lutte
contre la lentille gaspillage le
gaspillage alimentaire et autres et où
un volet sur les rep responsabilité
élargie des producteurs et vous aviez
tout un titre également qui habilite et
donner des habilitations sur un certain
nombre de choses très articles au départ
36 à l'issue de la commission
aménagement du territoire et
développement durable du sénat 76 à
l'issue de notre séance publique et donc
le texte adopté aujourd'hui au sénat qui
est examiné à l'assemblée nationale
comporte 76 articles qui seront
certainement amendé par nos collègues
députés
et cette loi tentera par exemple de
lutter contre les prolifération des
plastiques dans l'espace public se
concentrer sur les collectes hors foyer
c'est important
c'est très important puisque dans le
texte initial en réalité il n'y avait
pas de préoccupation en tout cas on ne
le voyait passer un texte très technique
et qui s'intéressait en fait à laval
c'est à dire qu'est ce qu'on fait une
fois que le déchet est là et on a
souhaité au sénat en réalité se poser la
question finalement qu'est-ce qu'on fait
de l'ensemble de nos plastique et pas
uniquement une catégorie de plastique
donné et c'est la raison pour laquelle
on a introduit en réalité en préambule
un au titre premier tout tout une tout
un volet sur tout ce qui était
dispositif contre le suremballage contre
la prolifération pardon des plastiques
dans l'espace public et dans leur foyer
puisqu'aujourd'hui on collecte bien dans
nos foyers puisque on a tous le bac
jaune chez nous et on sait qu'elle est
le geste à voir en revanche le hors
foyer aujourd'hui n'est pas réellement
dans les radars il n'existait pas en
termes de préoccupation dans le texte
initial et le sénat a souhaité
véritablement apporter ce plus cet
enrichissement au texte tony landes ali
à la résidence l'arbalète des prêts à
montigny le bretonneux avec un petit
groupe de voisins
vous avez décidé de réduire et de trier
vos déchets de façon écologique vous
avez trois bacs de compostage
800 litres ils sont installés dehors
dans votre résidence
comment ça se passe en fait chaque
personne durant la semaine donc collecte
dans son bios sont tous les déchets
verts les épluchures un peu tout ça et
puis en fait on se donne rendez-vous
donc le samedi matin pour pouvoir donc
déversés dans vos déchets ou sinon ils
le font de leur côté et c'est surtout
pour pouvoir me retourner un petit peu
de compost
donc on retourne sur 20 cm et ça permet
aussi de voir comment ça évolue s'il est
trop humide s'il est trop sec
ça permet aux possibles pour les grands
comme les petits voir toutes les petites
tous nos amis qui sont là dedans dans
les vers de terre les cloportes et du
coup ben finalement c'est un peu comme
un aquarium on dit devant comme ça et
puis on constate tout ce qui à quoi un
tiers de nos ordures peuvent être
compostables quels conseils pouvez-vous
donner peut-être aux futurs utilisateurs
bon en fait il faut s'y mettre c'est
assez simple et juste découper vos
épluchures comme ça et vont se
décomposer plus facilement
et puis on fait ça crée du lien social
en fait dans la résidence et bah en fait
on ce qu'on connaît mieux ses voisins et
et du coup on est contents d'y aller et
pour les enfants aussi en fait ils sont
les premiers content d'être là mettre la
main à la pâte
donc c'est l'agglomération de saint
quentin en yvelines qui propose des
composteurs individuels de quartier est
résidentiel jean michel chevallier
comment l'agglomération accompagne les
habitants dans cette transition
écologique
alors ce ce plan compost effectivement à
qualité mis en place en 2010 neuf et qui
fonctionne parfaitement bien
on doit en être à plus de 1000
composteur aujourd'hui installé autant
en résidentiel le sait à peu près facile
à appréhender
parce que finalement bas chaque
propriétaire gère son compost et sont
bio seau la démarche collective est un
peu plus compliqué donc je suis ravi
d'entendre que ça fonctionne bien et qui
a des expériences qui réussissent sur le
territoire je crois qu'il y en a cinq
résidences qui sont équipés aujourd'hui
il ya cinquante référent qui ont été
formés c'est ça qui est important en
fait c'est qu'il faut faire vivre en
résidentiel en tout cas il faut arriver
à faire vivre le projet et à impliquer
les gens en résidentiel c'est une
démarche volontaire
on va chercher son composteur crois que
ça doit coûter 25 euros il ya deux
modèles 300 litres et 600 litres et une
petite formation qui est dispensée à
l'agglo mais à dix pôles composteur vous
avez une petite réunion d'une heure au
cours de laquelle on vous rappelle les
fondamentaux
parce que ça marche pas tout seul vous
le disiez à très juste titre faut quand
même le surveiller leur tournée sa vie
un composteur sa vie donc il faut s'en
occuper en résidentiel c'est une
démarche volontaire c'est facile en
collectif il faut des référents et il
faut des gens qui animent le projet donc
je suis vraiment très content d'entendre
que ça fonctionne maintenant il faut
arriver à le dupliquer partout sur le
territoire
il y en a encore pas assez en
résidentiel enfin en collectif pardon
est justement par ce passage je voudrais
ajouter que on a une un organisme de
formation qui répond à toutes nos
questions et on n'est pas lâcher dans la
nature en fête donc
on est vraiment assisté c'est assez
rassurant que l'accompagnement c'est pas
qu'au début c'est aussi pendant toute la
durée de vie du projet et cette
installation était gratuite pour la
résidence mais c'est une contribution de
25 à 30 euros pour les résidentiels
oui tout à fait voilà il ya une
participation financière qui est très
minime par rapport au coût du composteur
mais il ya effectivement une petite
participation financière sur sur le
résidentiel
sacha bourguet vous avez lancé l'antenne
à saint-quentin-en-yvelines de youth for
climate le compostage ces bons justement
pour le climat oui c'est c'est logique
il faut recycler le plus de déchets
possible
beaucoup de déchets sont produits dans
le monde et en france et actuellement il
ya seulement 20 % des déchets qui sont
recyclés
c'est vraiment très peu et les du coup
vous avez dit qu un tiers des déchets et
et compostables c'est énorme ça pourrait
vraiment éviter beaucoup de déchets
qu'on retrouve dans la nature ou qui
sont brûlés actuellement et les déchets
c'est vraiment un vrai problème enfin ça
peut entraîner beaucoup de problèmes au
niveau de la biodiversité
on en retrouve dans la nature a retrouvé
90 dans les océans enfin tout le monde
connaît le 8e continent
toutes ces montagnes de plastique qui
flottent qui enfin qui détruisent qui
tue les poissons d'ici 2050 selon
certaines prévisions il pourrait voir
autant et la même masse de plastique
dans les océans queue de poisson
c'est pour ça que la jeunesse se montre
aussi sensible à ces causes
environnementales ça avec donc le groupe
des yeux sur km
on organise déclinologues assez
régulièrement pour nettoyer nature la
ville réduire le plus possible le nombre
de déchets un peu partout et on essaie
aussi de sensibiliser parce qu'au delà
de ramasser les déchets une fois qu'ils
sont produits l'idéal c'est de produire
un minimum de déchet pour c'est de
consommer un minimum de produits
globalement parce qu'il ya quand même
énorme plastique actuellement qui a
essayé d'initier les qui emballe
beaucoup d'emballages
visage unique et il faut vraiment éviter
de consommer et leur plastique comme ça
de surconsommer et essayer de cibler ses
produits les produits qu'ils utilisent
moins de plastique et qui créeront moins
de déchets par la suite vous aussi vous
avez effectué un changement et pas
n'importe lequel un changement de mode
de vie cyril klein vous vous êtes lancé
dans le défi zéro déchet plus de carton
ni plastique dans votre cuisine ça fait
trois ans que vous vous êtes lancé dans
ce mode de vie quels sont les
changements que vous avez opéré le
premier changement quand je me suis
installé à la verrière c'est
effectivement mettre en place tout
simplement un composteur puisque comme
on l'a dit tout à l'heure on réduit de
30% sont sa masse de sa masse de déchets
ensuite c'était de se poser les
questions on est question toute bête
c'est pourquoi je peux remplacer ce que
j'ai dans ma salle de bain par exemple
la bouteille de shampoing et c'est ce
que j'ai des solutions alternatives puis
on se rend compte qu'il ya effectivement
des solutions alternatives qui sont pas
à des nouveautés en soit c'est
l'utilisation d'un savon à la place d'un
shampooing la fabrication éventuellement
de produits de produits d'hygiène avec
avec des recettes assez assez simple à
mettre en oeuvre et des produits qui
sont qui sont plus simples que ce qu'on
peut trouver dans l'est dans les
produits du commerce
vous créez vous savez on est savant ça
va venir en créneau shampoing
aujourd'hui les savants l'entrain de
ceux en train de se lancer c'est un peu
plus c'est un peu plus compliqué mais ça
se fait ça se fait très bien
alors comment vous faites par exemple
pour lux emploi le shampooing c'est
c'est une base c'est une base très
simple c'est une base une base d'argile
éventuellement une poudre spécifiques en
fonction de la nature de vos cheveux je
vous prends de la poudre aux orties ou
la poudre de guimauve et c'est un
composant qui permet qui permet de faire
une émulsion un petit peu mousseuse
malheureusement la seule à seule
contrainte qu'on est à ce niveau-là
c'est de rajouter ce qu'on appelle du
essayer aujourd'hui donc il faut essayer
d'en être le mois le moins possible le
seuil est en soi c'est pas c'est pas
nocif par contre c'est un base de noix
de coco et notre coup ça vient de très
loin le traitement pour obtenir le seuil
est un traitement assez assez assez
contraignant donc voilà il mais au-delà
de ça au delà du savon c'est un peu une
anecdote le salon j'ai envie de dire
c'est toute la démarche qu'il faut
mettre en avant on parlait tout à
l'heure de recyclage faut pas oublier
que une des bases du zéro déchet en fait
ce sont la méthode des 5 hier la
première le premier r c'est refuser tout
simplement
donc c'est se mettre en se mettre en
tête de savoir refuser mais les
emballages plastiques on vous propose
supermarché un demande est ainsi
possible d'utiliser vos propres
contenants quand vous allez chez le
boucher jeu fromager chez les
poissonniers
ça commence à se faire commence à
s'ouvrir un petit peu au niveau des
grandes surfaces on peut déjà le faire
si on va au marché tout simplement
voilà nous on a décidé de quitter les
supermarchés par exemple pour revenir
sur le marché on parlait tout à l'heure
de lien social
on se rend compte que ça crée énormément
de liens
on se met à discuter avec beaucoup plus
de gens que quand on va faire ses
courses au supermarché
donc voila l idée du collectif very
green pour revenir plus largement
collectif c'est de proposer des ateliers
à l'ensemble des verriers roi et les
habitants de la communauté d'agglo voire
même plus large ce qu'on commence à être
un petit peu un petit peu connu tous les
mois jours justement appréhender la
façon de réduire ses déchets sur
différents domaines cosmétiques produits
ménagers mais surtout réduire en amont
sa production de déchets c'est vraiment
l'essentiel refusé réparer rendre à la
terre le recyclage c'est la dernière
c'est vraiment le dernier le dernier dr
c'est quand on peut pas faire autrement
en fait et c'est bien ça qu'il faut
qu'il faut garder en tête
on a parlé de plusieurs types de déchets
mais il ya aussi le gaspillage
alimentaire regardez ce reportage de
mélanie poker des yeux en forme d'écrou
une lumière sur la tête et un ventre
balance voici arthur le robot vérifie
chaque midi ce que jette les enfants de
l'école élémentaire des coudrais à
maurepas
si ça faisait six ans hebbadj pouvait
appuyer sur le bouton pour dire que
c'était le bon point c'est que j'ai pas
trop gaspiller semaine du tour
du coup il faut pas gâcher pour rien
parce qu'il ya des personnes qui n'ont
pas mangé
c'est important parce que bien mais qui
n'ont pas la chance comme angers partout
pas monsieur installé il ya trois mois
le robot a été pensé par les agents de
la commune il est une nouvelle étape du
programme de lutte contre le gaspillage
alimentaires dans les cantines scolaires
initié il ya un nom avec le principe
titre en grande forme d'enfants calibre
ses besoins calibre s'il a vraiment faim
si la ilaha illa moins faim voire
parfois s'ils aiment pas et du coup il
est au final quand il a terminé de
manger il jette évidemment mains des
l'espère cpd six ans il pas de
comprendre que je t'ai c'est pas bien et
que ça peut faire perdre des choses à
d'autres personnes qui sont dans le
besoin
le robot est calibré en fonction du menu
prévus chaque jour l'école continue
cette sensibilisation au gaspillage
le zéro déchet est ce vraiment possible
tony landes ali ben je pense que oui
c'est possible en fait c'est pour moi
c'est toute une histoire de temps en
fait donc si on prend le temps de le
faire on est conscient déjà de ce qu'on
fait on peut il prendre du plaisir et on
peut être que satisfait du résultat mais
c'est surtout pour moi prendre le temps
de le faire dans la loi alimentation
interdiction des bouteilles plastiques
en 2020 et des contenants en plastique
alimentaire qui seront supprimés vous
pensez que c'est réalisable
jean michel chevallier à priori oui tout
est réalisable après je pense que c'est
par étapes qu'il faut fonctionner et
qu'il faut aller vous montriez quelque
chose de très intéressant c'est le côté
pédagogique de cette démarche et ça ne
peut passer que par ça mais oui a priori
c'est possible
comme le disait monsieur à très juste
titre sur le le zéro déchet sur le 2-0
contenant c'est une question d'habitude
le gouvernement affiche aussi un
objectif de 100 % de plastique recyclé
pour 2025
un objectif qui peut être réellement à
temps madame décide alors en tout cas
c'est un objectif qui est élevé qui est
très fort je pense un petit peu comme
vous
voisin qu'il faut aller par étapes il
faut afficher cette volonté forte et
justement c'est le but
aujourd'hui de ces de cette loi de
donner un carcan en fait été un cadre
pour que tous nous prenions conscience
collectivement qu'en réalité on peut y
arriver
moi je le crois moi je suis convaincu il
y a à la fois l'échelle de proximité que
vous avez évoqué que vous portez très
bien d'ailleurs je trouve parce que ça
ne peut se faire que lorsque les deux
bouts se rejoignent c'est à dire
l'échelle de proximité est évidemment
l'échelon national parce que il est
fondamental que nous travaillons tous
ensemble collectivement
donc oui moi je crois que les objectifs
sont tout à fait atteignable
maintenant il faut qu'on se mettre au
travail et puis il faut que la loi
économie circulaire soit votée à
l'assemblée
affaire à suivre vous êtes d'accord
sacha je pense que c'est possible mais
qui en est fait il faut un effort commun
que seulement tout le monde accepte
grâce à un effort pédagogique fait par
des associations par exemple de réduire
son confort et donc ses déchets de faire
des petits efforts comme à aller faire
un compost
comme elle est toujours bien faire le
tri réduire sa consommation ça mais si
tout le monde fait des efforts et prend
conscience de l'enjeu climatique c'est
possible la loi gaspillage et économie
circulaire un volet qui concerne les
dépôts sauvages celle de carrières sous
poissy est l'une des plus grandes
déchetteries sauvages de france
on l'a surnommé d'ailleurs la mer de
déchets elle représente 38 mille tonnes
comment lutter contre ces décharges
sauvages faut-il sanctionner plus cyril
klein faut-il sanctionner plus
sanctionnés
faux faux que c'est faux que ça ait du
sens il faut trouver les faut trouver
les responsables et sur une décharge qui
fait 36 38 mille tonnes j'imagine bien
que on parle de plusieurs plusieurs
centaines ou un de milliers de personnes
qui vont qui vont à cette décharge
publique
il faut travailler en amont encore une
fois il ya des associations qui font un
travail extraordinaire ce niveau là
c'est l'association des marcheurs
cueilleurs qui sensibilise via les
réseaux sociaux
justement aux différentes décharges
sauvages qu'on peut trouver dans le
département est un peu plus loin
maintenant puisqu'il commence à avoir
des antennes dans toute la france est
bon mais toujours points toujours le
doigt la grosse décharge sauvage mais
suffit d'aller vous promener dans les
bois où là il ya toujours des déchets en
fait on revient toujours à la même à la
même question c'est sensibiliser les
gens qui prennent conscience que ça peut
plus ça peut plus fonctionner comme ça
le jeu consomme je jette
c'est pas c'est pas c'est pas c'est pas
un credo qui va falloir continuer à
suivre très longtemps si on veut espérer
renverser la vapeur et vous vous croyez
à cette démarche pollueur payeur ça ça
je pense comme il l'a dit en effet on ne
peut pas se permettre d'acheter quoi
consommer et j'étais suite les déchets
chacun de prendre conscience et prendre
ses responsabilités sur ce qu'ils
achètent acheter quelque chose qui
minimisera les déchets qui leur a par la
suite et on peut aussi faire des efforts
et à les ramasser les déchets
régulièrement affaire à technologies fpt
quand on va se balader en forêt ou qu'on
fait un trajet à pied histoire d'éviter
de prendre la voiture par exemple pour
montpellier
on peut si on passe on voit des déchets
sur notre chemin les ramasser en prendre
quelques uns elle évite à la poubelle et
si enfin les petits ruisseaux font les
grandes rivières et donc si tout le
monde fait ça par exemple à montigny ou
en france il y aura déjà beaucoup moins
de déchets dans la nature sera d'avancer
dans une réaction au terme de ces drames
moi je reviens sur votre question qui
avait déposé sur les sanctions moi je
dis oui il faut des sanctions aussi je
suis un petit peu plus affirmative que
monsieur que la sur ce point là parce
qu'aujourd'hui nous avons en fait
constaté aussi que l'ensemble est en
tout cas une grande partie de nos dépôts
sauvages dans la nature carrière en fait
partie et l'as proviennent aussi d'un
certain type de matériau qui proviennent
aussi du bâtiment et c'est un sujet
c'est la raison pour laquelle d'ailleurs
dans le texte de loi économie circulaire
nous l'avons sorti des habilitations
pour le mettre en dur dans le texte avec
un certain nombre de dispositifs et de
sanctions qui sont tout à fait possibles
ça passe aussi par en fait là ce qu'on
appelle la police du maire donner un peu
plus de pouvoirs aux élus locaux pour
qu'ils puissent constater prendre le feu
quand il a flag rendez lui aussi réagir
et sanctionné en fait donc vous avez
tout une gradation que nous avons
proposées dans ce texte et qui au moment
où je vous parle puisque le texte a été
examiné en commission à l'assemblée
nationale
nos collègues députés a priori nous
suivent
ils ont amendé ils ont enrichi un
certain nombre de sujets mais je pense
malgré tout qu'il faut qu'à un moment
donné nous puissions sanctionné et je
crois moi je rejoins en revanche tout ce
que vous dites bien évidemment parce que
la sensibilisation la prévention sont
fondamentales en matière d'environnement
je crois que ce que vous faites c'est
c'est vraiment les champs de proximité
et c'est fondamental parce que ça
commence comme ça vous avez parlé
d'efforts je crois que oui nous devons
tous faire collectivement des efforts
mais vous avez parlé aussi de prise de
conscience et ça je crois que c'est une
réalité la prise de conscience est là et
des mouvements des associations sont des
véritables alertes tir de la sonnette
d'alarmé suffisamment souvent maintenant
aux prêts à la fois des élus et des
pouvoirs publics pour que comme vous
voyez le vecteur législatif maintenance
et mise en route en tout cas en france
c'est le cas et moi je voudrais aussi
quand même enlevé une idée qui est très
répandue en france
disons que nous sommes très mauvais on
n'est pas si mauvais que cela on a
énormément d'efforts encore à faire
c'est évident donc ça c'est nécessaire
mais je crois que la conscience
collectif et là à travers des
associations comme vous à travers des
actions que l'on peut avoir dans les
territoires et puis à travers les élus
parce que les collectivités et les
communes
aujourd'hui il n'y en a pas une qui ne
se soit pas saisie d'une façon ou d'une
autre de ce sujet là donc major est
malgré tout optimiste et je crois qu'il
faut le rester là dessus mais faut pas
baisser les bras
c'est compliqué et pour rappel une
entreprise qui déversent des déchets sur
un site comme celui de carrières sous
poissy s'expose à 75000 euros damende
deux ans de prison et la saisie du
véhicule à ont clôturé cette émission on
a parlé du compostage de la réduction
des emballages du déficit zéro déchet
pensez vous à d'autres solutions pour
réduire nos déchets petit tour de table
messieurs chevalier la réduction de
déchets c'est une chaîne et c'est une
somme de mayom il ya plein de bonnes
idées
il ya plein d'acteurs ou nizier très
juste titre il ya les élus il ya l'agglo
il ya les assauts on peut pas y arriver
seul donc voilà c'est c'est toute une
chaîne d'idées qui vont se mettre en
place en application c'est une chaîne
d'acteurs
les élus les associations les habitants
surtout c'est eux qu'il faut qu'on
arrive à convaincre le tri c'était une
première étape
ça permettait de valoriser maintenant il
faut passer à la deuxième étape c'est
plus produire de déchets ou de moins
produire de déchets moi j'aime bien dire
que l'objectif à saint quentin
on a créé cette culture du tri et
quelques années il faut qu'on arrive
maintenant à créer cette culture de la
prévention de la production du déchet
stonehill ordalie vous allez continuer
le compostage oui voilà c'est bon c'est
ancré à s'est vraiment fait
et puis en plus on est de plus en plus
nombreux dans la résidence donc ça fait
plaisir et je pense que l'on va pas
lâcher et c'est vecteur de lien social
ouais saffar je pense que comme vous
l'avez dit c'est une somme d'actions qui
peuvent mener à une réduction globale
des déchets donc les composts le tri est
en effet comme vous dites le plus
important maintenant c'est de réduire
globalement la consommation et je pense
que c'est devant par là que doit passer
la réduction des déchets une solution
aussi pour réduire ses déchets c'est de
promouvoir le
les achats de proximité donc remettre au
centre de au centre de nos achats les
producteurs locaux au travers des amap
par exemple et c'est vraiment voilà
regarder ce qui se fait autour de nous
il n'ya pas besoin d'acheter des
produits qui viennent de l'autre bout de
l'europe ou l'autre bout du monde pour
manger correctement par exemple et ça
c'est vraiment très important juste un
point par rapport au recyclage des
déchets même si on a même si on atteint
en 2025 100 % de déchets plastiques
recyclés faire attention le plastique ne
se recyclent pas à l'infini
on peut les recycler et après on le maul
donc il faut vraiment réduire sa
conservation plastique merci à tous
d'avoir participé à sept huit sociétés
et merci à vous d'être fidèle à notre
chaîne très belle soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]
on